thank you to hellofresh for sponsoring
this video more on them after the
[Music]
reaction citizens of the Reche Nation
this is my Adam Sandler voice cuz today
we're going to watch That's My Boy and
I'm here with my boy Aaron
Alexander over there my name's Aaron and
that's drawn over there hi guys and now
I'm Andy Samberg anyway we're going to
watch That's my boy just a quick note
for youtube Greg did prep us didn't
spoil anything but just going to say
this directly there is some riness in
this movie none of it is real all of it
is fake is a fantasy it is a comedy this
is a farce it is all made up all of the
footage you see is conducted by film
making professionals it's not real be
mindful of that this is a fantasy we're
about to embark on all right the fantasy
it's an illusion we're going to go into
Fantasy Land here for a minut f
absolutely so I want don't you go ahead
while we're here leave a like for comedy
cuz I have a feeling we're going to
laugh a little bit also subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to get
updated every time one of these
reactions and reviews
drops just like running downstairs when
you're leaning forward and you're just
got to put words under your feet you
know what I mean but anyway hey exactly
yes and thank you to the folks at
prepper for helping us cut down these
highlights it is a task especially I
imagine for a movie like this one and
hey if you want to get the complete
That's My Boy experience see everything
that doesn't make these reaction
highlight reels come on over to
patreon.com theal rejects sync up with
your own copy and enjoy That's My Boy
alongside Aaron and Ian and while you're
there you can check out all the other
stuff that Greg and I got streaming with
reaction highlights watch alongs
included it's a ball it's a blast Aaron
do you have anything else to tell the
people before we hop into the show I'm
to find out where my boy
is I feel like I sound like March
Simpson it's okay just do the whole
video in that voice we're good let's hop
into this let's watch the
[Music]
movie this is going to be a good
experience Yep this is how we
start
I feel a little baited and switched that
it's not The Offspring but what can you
do third row you should take Jolene man
I heard you got big wow Jolene I'm just
not into girls anymore dude what I'm
into guys too no no no no no that's not
what I meant but live your best life
South Boston youth hockey boy I'm into
women
uh-oh Gra C Katherine Isabelle what are
you doing
here oh it's not one to one but Eva
Murray kind of looks like Katherine
Isabelle all right C me some
slack oh no oh
Christ hide those cats
elf hey Mary I got two tickets to Van
Hal this weekend what time should I pick
you up it is Miss mle Donnie but I am
your teacher not your girlfriend friend
uhoh who say anything about girlfriends
let's just start the summerling couple
of wow kiddo don't get all psycho on me
right away that is a month's detention
yes ma'am that kid has the rids as the
kids say he's got of he's got some
R he's the one earring so you know he he
participates
in you're in a lot of trouble Donnie
uh-oh wait oh no you're not going to
tell my dad are you he'll kick my ass he
he's crazy what were you trying to do
anyway impress your friends well I mean
kind of I guess I feel something coming
on I feel a little crush on me uhoh no
no so oh no oh god oh
Jesus no oh I felt it I felt from the
hallway from the way she was talking to
I don't know I'm supposed to say right
now your mouth Donnie oh my God Shu
christe I mean that's somebody's thing
you know I've been watching you all year
Lord Lord in Christ okay you were
jumping up and down and your little
Larry Bird short shorts and sweating
like a jar of pickles in the hot sun oh
my that is a metaphor that was so hot oh
my God it's actually it's a simile cuz
she said like is this really happening
yep it's happening right now what was
Office what was happening on set when
you shot this right how did you how did
you get away with this you want to do it
cuz I I made before lots of ways oh my
God me out from behind I'll teach you oh
God kids if you muck around you're going
to find out my God oh my God that's that
he was
there oh my God God that's crazy wow if
you saw any of that scene thank the
editors
jeez he was like that's my
boy you know
probably and here Sandler is just
casting like the coolest looking kid who
could potentially have played wow oh
God it's a good cover story miss
mcgerkle or whatever her name is
[Music]
oh my God supposed to be 13 Jesus oh my
God what this woman is bold this I have
so many feelings right now e gr class
president I promise to so good at this
ah no what oh my God what I promise to
do my best to lower prices at the school
store and this is messed up oh this is
messed up
this is so feel so strange watching this
so mixed
feelings yo no dude some have greatness
thrust upon them whoa Jeepers no poop no
crap what did you think was going to
happen the gym teacher how old was this
kid that's what I'm wondering this actor
was 18 FL wrapped around her was that is
that Isaiah Mustafa from the from the
old commercial with a big old
beard how very
[Applause]
strange oh jeez the kid's an American
hero this is your weird double like
double standard yeah if it was flipped
around it be really this is completely
messed up this is really creepy right
and that's the way young boys Minds I'm
sure work as well I am aware that a lot
of people think that this young man is
not really a victim but someone that's
living the ultimate teenage boys
fantasy Jesus
Christ Mary Beth mcgarrick will rise for
sentencing this relation you and me both
Kido that's exactly how I feel and I
quot he makes me feel like there's a
rainbow coming out of my be yeah yes you
knew it was coming Pete the maximum
penalty 30 years in the Massachusetts
women's Penitentiary damn the court
grants custody of The Unborn Child to
Donald Burger's
father jeez God dang take care of our
baby D this I'll never stop loving you
that is just mental little little bit
that lady's hair is
mental sure
30 years later our love is
real what is
happening he becomes famous how old were
the writers when they did the first
draft of
this they wrote it in
the80s oh
wow think and
feel I got a
son everyone loves Anie he on um oh
what's that guys name [__] arini oh Hall
that's who he was on the show
with your Flinch pansy go ahead I don't
need you I'm Donnie freaking
Burger it's that guy [__] what's his
name Cory two
Cory that kid is burning through that
money but he's having a good time doing
it oh no oh no not for long it's going
to be a
burnout there's my boy there he is Rush
with the One Headlight open I want to
know what the VIN diagram is of comedy's
that feature like a a heavy Rush element
like a lot of comedies about dudes who
love Rush was three years in prison
three years yeah you haven't paid taxes
since '94 Donnie whoa they were taking
it out automatically that's what you
thought and they said it's the stupidest
thing they ever
heard if you can pay the balance off by
the end of the weekend they'll suspend
the sentence oh okay okay there you go
oh no 43,000 43 Grand no
Jesus oh no don't screw up my Tom Brady
poster it's my favorite one look at that
jawline fraking Tom Brady does have a
tough drawline I'll give him
that it's the only thing I'll give him
no more championships this is Tubby
toque fat guy going to run the Marathon
odds in him winning 8,000 to1 but this
cat's got wheels on him I think he's
going to win I really do what all right
I'll put 20 on the
fat what about your kid maybe he can
come up with the D we don't talk no more
he kind of moved out when he turned 18
and uh that's the last I seen him yeah I
bet I love that little Han Solo more
than anything in the world
too W Han Solo Burger coolest name in
the world right no I I think he's sec
secretly deep down wants a supportive
fatherly relationship he misses
you hey it's us a don't we look great
yeah well you look good I kind of look
like a
ventriloquist
no got our faces and our names it just
seems like anyone could find us oh no
you have your security undies yep right
here there's stranger things than
walking around with an extra pair of
underwear for emergencies stranger
thanks we're going to have the best
wedding ever okay I hope she really
loves him me
too got to stay strapped you and me both
buddy okay you never know come up with
that money huh oh my oh the only thing
I'm good at is being a Johnny Burger no
one wants to pay for that anymore a
Donnie get it girl wow my face is your
toilet oh my
God
stay useful my
friend holy cow that's my son he almost
said the title thought you said he was a
fatty no no no he must have lost a way
or some cuz I swear to God that's that's
my boy
title he sh it to Peterson he changed
his name
why that's how you do it Peterson is one
of the youngest large cap hedge fund
managers in the financial industry oh we
got rich on us huh
what the
god Spider-Man taught her well MVP of
the movie right there maybe your son
could help you financially this kid
changed his name he doesn't even want to
be a burger anymore he's not going to
want to talk to me maybe he wants to be
a taco yeah or a pizza looking hot
doctor's orders let's welcome oh no
let's
go this is the the most you K
intersection
dance club also a round of applause for
Nick swartson holding it down in every
Adam Sandler movie King yep Steve these
are my parents Gerald and Helen the
daughter is a sweetheart you can tell
she likes Todd for Todd not because he's
going to be rich wouldn't want my boy to
end up with some gold digger like the
last three I married
huh yeah all
three well guys
this
H tell me what it is or I shall poke you
quite viciously with a cocktail stick
I've always said that if the finance
game was an amusement park your son
would be a roller coaster and I would
just ride him all day
[Laughter]
long like Ling long makes it better
yep I modeled the bathing suit for a w
worth advertisement well you still have
quite a figure on you oh my God that's
the dad from uh boy meet's world that's
Sean dad recogize that voice anywhere
Chad's here uhoh this continues The Boy
Meets World cameos I am not going to
grab game that we're now
playing Dad how are sir you look great
thank you sir hey Chad I'm TI oh god
oh yeah this is my fiance pleasure to
meet you Chadwick are you a soldier oh
Christ sailor no Airman no well then I'd
prefer you take your fingers away from
your forehead and you shake my hand like
the civilian you are oh my
God you ever do anything to hurt my
sister I will take my government issued
service your bver stick it straight up
your poop shoot and C F yeah buddy this
guy's got Tom Cruz energy can I see Rand
Moran possibly yeah you're going to need
an appointment but you know what tell
him zie Berg is out here he'll be pretty
shsy to see an old friend uhoh Mr
Morgan's on vacation he's on vacation
that's ter Vanilla
Ice International sensation Vanilla Ice
get out your Sandler Cameo bingo card
stamp we were friends until you banged
my mother I didn't know it was her I
swear to God it's not like her last name
is ice you should have known by the
[Laughter]
haircut passed it down I'm going to
prison if I don't get 43 lives so what
do you think I got that kind of money
royalties from myze baby you must be
loaded a queen took 50% sh took the
other 60% sure and owe money when that
[__] gets played man the other 6
11% I work at an ice rink now I deep
friy chicken nuggets man I get you a
deal on a barbecue sauce packet jesz a
barbecue sauce packet is crazy maybe I
should call your mother she'll give me
the money I know that what what
what my
[Music]
beard
oh my god when I walk down the street
people are like there's that guy I'm
still big dude there's that guy that's
the
sequel I need 43 G Birds what what are
we talking about right now need
$43,000 are you back on drugs
yeah that's actually a good idea reunion
me and Miss mcara together again live
from a woman's prison oh my there's a
whole other movie happening over there
woman's prison very sexy
mhm freaking framing
oh you're just staring at it you know
you could that after I leave the room
but I need an answer ah he's due for
dinner it's true going to eat man's
going to eat you get yourself and your
actual kid up to the women's prison this
weekend I will shoot it I will give you
50 grand in cash wow did you know that
Todd is really great with numbers you
got to see this oh Jamie 52 * 77 beep
beep
8434 oh he could just be making that up
oh God Grandma you good over there oh
Grandma's killing it
Grandma's sure you're not a China oh
wow
wow as you should sir as you should must
be Jamie you're like even harder than
you looked in the paper look at your
hair blowing in the wind like ta Kain
when was dry humping that carat
uh and you must be Johnny what's you
matter chubby never even mentioned me
chubby I'll take the blw back just you
got to read it though
it's
yes that's it's pretty bu Spencer's
Gifts Nevers
me yes that's exactly what she find as
Spencer Gifts
oh my gosh I'm so sorry uh let me just
yes go oh sorry those are yours
I those are yours oh you said your
parents were dead um no they are super
dead have You Met My Dead dad he's super
dead he's back from the grave I'm his
best friend your best friend I saved his
life it was like one of them train trag
kind of jeels my man over here I see him
he drops his burrito on the track
homeboy leaps down there and he tries to
retrieve the burrito as you do I'm like
this guy's about to die and he don't
know it I down there myself right and I
give him a little shoving The Hiding get
out of the way
buddy this thing's going to hit me I had
a Kung Fu instructor who taught me how
to tighten the diaphragm and I bring it
in there and I feel the trangle bite my
eyes are closed rips my shirt off
[Music]
can't believe I've never heard that
story before why wouldn't you just get
another burrito
Todd
fair fair
question where are you staying Donnie oh
he's not staying oh for sure I me invite
him to stay here uh-oh you are my best
friend Guy and Jamie you can be my
friend ug ug he has a tye rest with an a
with an AE with an AE I created a whole
fake life just so I can get away from
you jeez your mother's Sick by the way
no she's not I don't believe you they
don't know how long she's
gone I hope those come back yeah
Saturday's the last visiting day before
the big surgery so oh boy you want me to
go visit my sick mom that I haven't
talked to in years in prison the day
before my wet correct not happening at
all oh I did everything for you buddy
and I never gave you an ounce of sh [__]
about nothing you never gave me nothing
I gave you a snake yeah then it died
after it ate all your
quo I never learned how to swim I don't
even know how to ride a bike you know
how humiliating that is a I used to put
an oven man in my hand he would cheer
you up all the time when you were sad
don't be upset young man I'm your best
friend even though I'm an oven man you
know what I do remember you making me
drive you home from the beach cuz you
got too drunk oh you're a millionaire
now and you're marrying a hot chick I
must have done a pretty decent job is a
d don't you think oh yeah you want to
check in on your pretty decent job whoa
you're a junkie who's your supplier cuz
I'll smack that motherfu around insulin
you I'm a diabetic cuz you let me eat
cake and lollipops for breakfast every
day a h solo don't be like this Han Solo
my name's Todd Now call yourself Han
Solo you're dressed like him oh he is
yeah you have any Axe Body Spray no
Donnie I don't have any Axe Body Spray
because I'm not a douchebag oh shots
fired at the sponsor who gave us money
for that product placement joke we got a
party to attend hey whoa whoa whoa how
about you put on a tie okay it's a
cocktail party not a Quiznos
opening Quiznos SS and I was thinking if
we hedge our position on oil we could oh
my
God oh my goodness no the little
this man does not believe in pants nope
or colored shirts short pants
onlyny come on say hi to everyone you
got to tell your fiance the truth about
your your parentage buddy nah it's not
going to happen oh it is at no point in
this movie is that going to happen Steve
SPO Todd's boss not relevant
where is that back is that back because
I've been dying for that to come back
what's up
[Laughter]
what must have been the most fun day on
set yeah no yes that was Terri no
grandma no you're supposed to drop the
pee Todd yeah Tod right oh my God you're
right it is him hey and Rachel Dr hey
you remember that kid who got his
teacher pregnant in Somerville wait a
minute that is you Donnie Burger didn't
you and your teacher have a kid yeah
yeah Hano Burger yeah Han Solo Han Solo
oh God he actually became
a yep do you think you would ever your
wife yeah I mean I love she's a hot
little number I would have killed kill
to bang my eighth grade biology teacher
Mrs Khan I used should dream of of of
dissecting her with
my Jesus my school librar is glasses to
wear while
[Music]
I'm I'm sorry you you want to run that
back real
quick Todd was working at the cubicle
next to mine one year 12 weeks and one
day ago when you met a pretty girl at
the gym named Jamie
a how many days is that Todd Computing
Steve
be1 what oh it's actually
450 Battle of The Brainiac yeah this guy
for go out about leaper oo okay he's got
a math he a math God your mother was a
math teacher and I was pretty much a
whiz kid myself the ability to make a
bong out of a Taco Bell cup doesn't make
you a whiz kid mother
[Laughter]
started saying that you got Fenway pack
in your back yet well I had that buil my
son started Little League he never used
it a little douchebag just sat in his
room listening to reggae Ross Trent ding
ding ding ding whoa let's see what we
got
pleas please don't me got a mini green
monster oh nice all right boss it's
pretty boss
you awake
sweeth she's going to hit her in the
face
hey even
better hit one to that 2-year-old he
hasn't gotten one yet something bad's
about to
happen yes oh nice
kid I wonder if they just caught that or
if they got the kid to do oh
yeah this is this is impressive you know
bow down Bow Down
yeah get that
slowmo
no right in the
throat come on you're fine you don't
care about your beyon I
think oh
no you oh my
God put some dirt on it man some on it
walk get off jeez Jesus kid got an arm
wear him if you
want I want
toah blah blah okay let's get that in 3D
guess what's on TV I'm Mr M what is that
the Donnie Burger story don't you get
money every time that [__] is shown last
check I got for that was 85 a is Han Sol
going to do the show at the women's
prison with you you know I haven't
discussed any particulars with him huh
get the cake no walnuts no excuses you
suck dude that chick sucks don't marry
her what was she yelling at what' you do
wrong she's just stressed out for little
wedding you sure she's not stressed out
about maybe have you have you been going
uh a lot of times girls I've met over
the years when they've been ragging on
me and yelling at me and [__] if I kiss
the kind of go oh my God are you serious
I can't even take my shirt off in front
of other people because of you a oh let
me jog your
memory oh my God new kids what the hell
a fishy lens holy [__] the heads are all
war now a cuz I got it when I was in
third grade my body
grew Jesus
Christ in third grade and I'm fine with
it you
know oh yeah
de Fantasy
Island it's uh you playing the plane yet
yeah what's his name [__] no just taking
no I'm
not
no oh my God oh my God oh my God
no
do just wrestling just wrestling man
you're looking at an all state russing
champion and I got the winner okay well
he won why is he hard what the he's
always apparently he stays he stays
ready we weren't wrestling at all I was
losing oh my
God what the let's go let's go Jesus
okay all right oh we don't like
you
talking oh my God oh
my stop it please God oh go let's go
that's why I do before each one of these
reactions man like ready let's
go he's been waiting for this you went
you went I tap out you like S Todd I
mean you like sticking your dirty booger
fingers in
her is he drinking a whole bottle of
mesal dirty booger fingers is crazy
probably why his son ran off his what
what who it's son about what did he say
what did you hear did he say something
just look at the first page of that book
he's been handing out to everyone the
flesh light book head in the class Head
of the Class only
withs
wow
a weirdly got me I don't
know can I get a hug right now no no no
no a don't marry this woman rich people
magazines let's see what we
got if I hadn't pattied with a husband
so many times I would but it's
disrespectful to one oh Jesus Donnie's
partied with Epstein you know uh oh oh
definitely
hello you really wear a model aren't you
Grandma nope nope
nope a note for me if you're seeing any
of this just you know be
grateful this is visible on YouTube you
know thank the editors I can take it to
the Speak Easy we this is very natural
you know this is natural part of the The
Human Experience I wonder what her
experience is like filming this
movie what have you done to me what have
you done to me oh my oh my we got go for
round two but give me a little bit oh my
oh wow I hope they end up together me
too they deserve each other I wonder if
they recast the the teacher or if it's
going to be just the same actress in
older makeup or something oh oh God yeah
buddy no you knew this was coming
P No don't touch it yes grab them all
put it down there's so many
[Music]
tissues
oh oh God no please God okay grab more
tissues coat your hands with them and
then grab you'll get sick he's got
postnasal drips
y yep that's what he's got
yep I feel the same way oh
no
[Laughter]
no damn it no damn it no tissue you
cannot rely on tissues man tissue's
flake it's just glue it's glue it is
glue it's glue it's Elmer's Elmer's if
he's really under the weather maybe it's
best if he doesn't so
much that was a good punch line the old
broad knew I was whacking to her time
didn't she that's all but your improvs
are awesome po Nas whatever you sh wow
I'll have you know She Bangs me all the
time all right She Bangs She Bang She
Bang she move uh she move she
move
[Music]
whoa James Khan what are you doing here
I thought that was Ric Flair for a
second I'll take either
but damn he couldn't get Al paccino so
he's got James Khan y settled we should
start with the uh the father of the gro
his father passed away he died in an
explosion I'm I'm truly sorry to hear
that song he deserved it what is that
supposed to mean he just you know wasn't
a great dad dang uhoh that's the fourth
Commandment right there brother your
father he he abused you did he was a
murderer no father I'm sorry I father
was a drink me every day with a rake oh
my God hear Miss smack talking him like
some baby little princess not here in
the house of the Lord James Khan really
showed up intense shot at yeah with the
shaky Cam and James Kong got in the
character you know I can't hear a word
you're saying all I can focus on is your
[__]
breath waa
dude I'd like to show you the garden for
a minute I'm sure you would okay you
know what let's just y oh my God yeah
buddy what a punch put him up man he's
pretty RI for an
old let's go con get him oh my
god did him with the teeth killed the
guy in the ring that's why he became a
priest
oh oh
Jee there's one nice
nice again
twer a whole other place right now he's
speaking gay speaking in tongues you
know what maybe just run get
the I'm not going to
run ouch Chad to
Chad to the kid right now let's go Han
Solo son Han Solo son
we
hey again
again brought to you by Rolling
Rock oh man this is all my fault I
shouldn't have hit the guy with the
bottle like a [__] over here no now
Donnie I will not let you take the blame
for this you had to do it you saved his
life again yes ma'am sound of that
bottle so
familiar there a different bottle I mean
well where are we going to get married
now we got kicked out of the church hey
what is everybody's problem you were
awesome out there you kicked ass you
should be proud of yourself proud of
myself for what a by the way thanks for
the fatherly advice guy nah he's
starting to shape you he's teaching you
a lesson or two about standing up for
yourself stand up for yourself you got
Moxy kid church has freaked the kid out
ever since his father's funeral after
the explosion all that was left of his
dad was like a kneecap little bit of
check the more important detail he
actually saw a squirrel run into the
coffin and uh squeak out of there with
his dad's ball bag in his mouth yep
saving those for
winter was he there enough for the kid
maybe not but uh you know he probably
felt bad about it you know there's
nothing he can do about it now so uh
tosy oh sometimes I do still have night
nightmares oh boy that squirrel its
demonic eyes tiny piece of skin flapping
in its
mouth one scraggly hair oh
no I'm pretty tied into the church crowd
rageaholics Anonymous and whatnot wow oh
my god let's go maybe a younger guy
younger guy how about a black guy oh I
now I like that it's very Urban very
Street oh it still doesn't get us a
church well I'll tell you where I would
tighten out if I was these two sexy kids
I like to eat lobster oh boy don't you
love the pero Gorge you know what maybe
a little more girly [__] up on
the got it got it yeah yeah yeah
yeah you guys have fun in the bachelor
party go okay we're having a bachelor
party just like my thing man I cannot
tell what directions it's going with her
I feel like he's not going to man up
marrying her I'm getting like I'm
getting hangover Vibes yeah to your
bachelor party package here at he spa
for men she's familiar
he all right all right now we're talking
what turn is this going to take come on
here to the kid he getting off cucumber
water yep that's how I feel what the is
this that's what I feel that's what I'd
say used with cucumber rose petal and
harvest Sandalwood spit it out again
Sandalwood show my shiny
promise me promise me
oh is this an interesting reaction I
wonder if she told if they told her she
he was going to do that
right what's this sir TI you know if you
give me a full package it includes Scalp
Treatment reflexology how much is it to
take on my pickle and I'm not asking for
a up the ass I just want you to just it
a little bit this isn't a
brothel Jesus Christ no so what you're
just going to get a job in front of all
of us I don't know am I nope I have
worked very hard on this night Dawn and
you're being just plain rude yes yes
Will Forte Chili Pepper in it up red hot
red hot I'm telling you I can't let my
son have a my son of a gun best friend
have his b poy be this you guys got your
face covered at leprechaun [__] besides
it's not like you can throw together a P
of their party this late oh don't
challenge him could have six chicks
making out with each other on our laps
in 10 minutes you going to get
our I'm telling you the hottest chicks
the best Denver armet you have to eat
one
best you killing it oh and you brought a
military man you think you can keep that
detention for a couple
hours already on
it I like I like how serious this guy is
hello I'm Phil I'm married with four
children and I've actually only seen
three vaginas in my entire life my wives
my babies and my aunts once by
accident number four baby there's the
Lonely Island song about doing it with
your ant I'm Todd nice to meet you I
know who you are Han Solo oh uhoh no you
can't don't worry your secret's safe a
they're going to get
married take a sh of he going to cheat
on his fiance uhoh she's better for you
it's been a while since I've seen a
comedy this ranchy it's Rony and it's
really funny you know I'm I am laughing
a whole lot I got to say it's that blunt
force comedy of just keep find the line
and then go through
[Laughter]
it I have those be
goggles
suck that's amazing oh that's incredible
bacon and legs that is excellent give me
a gift of course I got you I think uh
keep
I oh no what an earring yeah I know
about D it's your mom's my mom gave me
and I thought maybe we could keep it in
the family you know just kind of keep it
going generation to generation Pierce
one ear yeah but I don't have a pierced
ear on going pierce it right now pierce
his peeee pierce his s do it just do it
it's all going to hurt buddy you got a
nice no we're sticking to the ears get
an infection come
here
[Applause]
yeah how Bloody is it it's hella bloody
remember you put it in the wrong part of
his ear am I
bleeding you know what it's time for to
get you back together with the old game
I just hope the guy was talk to me are
we going to see his friends from middle
school
[Music]
hey sorry about what happened vany
vanwinkle Travis vanwinkle
Rob Rob Van Winkle that's all I've been
waiting for all these years Man a simple
apology a me and my boy got a little
head out on you but you got any desire
to get wasted with us a more than life
itself in fact I might have a little
head start you guys whoa
yeah there's got to be a Vanilla Ice
strain out there oh most definitely yeah
vanilla OG or something
oh
[Music]
bonding my man that's awesome whoa whoa
the Sparks on those jeez I wonder if
those were really sparking can't imagine
they whoa [__] run run run
run whoa this seem like fun
guys those 1800 lye Billboards are
everywhere just cing Mayhem jeez that's
what I call Saturday night how did they
get whoa dude no jeez what aim oh wow
W [__]
Jesus Remember in first grade when you
were supposed to pick me up after school
you left me waiting for 5 hours a well I
[__] in my pants all right and I had to
walk all the way home alone with [__] in
my pants a I'll never forget you again I
I swear to God throw the things away no
no you're going to need them [__]
under you don't need that you better
than that guy [__] it okay fck squeeze
it out and [__] immediately shits his
pants
yeah no be that like that Derek comedy
sketch with Donald
Glover I think the principal pooped his
pants no it's in you buddy I don't know
how I got you I ain't going to let you
fall don't let me go I won't let you
fall let go all he going to get the bike
are we going to get one more that's my
boy before the mov over come on come on
come ony I'm with you my boy he's gonna
get hit he's gonna get hit oh
no yeah
buddy oh
my they definitely obscured his face a
little bit dude I'm trying to make love
to my
wife what the hell my God how many naked
auditions do these movies require I love
you
son a damn I've always loved you all
right sorry to Spring that on you like
that
it's all right it's cool why do you not
call me Donny when no one's around you
can call me dad oh what about Daddy what
about poppy
papy H so what what time we going to go
to the prison tomorrow oh go to the
prison I'll go yeah he needs that money
he cancel that that's why I talk to the
warden and he says that your your mother
was just pulling our leg she's only got
the chicken parts oh no she said she was
dying because they give you better food
if you're Wicked [__] like that like
beeron or beoni not like the usual
prison
slop look at me oh my God you pissing on
yourself like that Kieran J call album
seen a lot more like strong streams in
this movie than I have in a long time
boy oh here we go oh yeah let's get it
let's get it let's get it m we've been
waiting for so now it's time that you
try the real thing what are we doing
they're not going to do it you never
know yeah I wouldn't put it past this
movie I think they will no no no don't I
can't don't
you ah okay we're going graduate I see
all right fine the old chy
painting he let's go I'm going to ride
you like a model chees like a model te I
wonder what it's like to be one of the
actors who gets to be the the horny old
lady it must be fun I guess I'm sure
it's wonderful it's like a whole cast of
actor like an archetype unto itself you
can make a documentary about all the
women who play this
role you look beautiful oh no you can't
be that messed up to try to oh boy to
try to have sex with a dress no no no
no
no don't ruin the
dress oh my God help
me you puked all over my wedding dress
a I just found my wedding dress covered
in barf and and something else something
no don't look at it don't look at it he
sneezed on it he sneezed on it don't
don't don't don't lick it don't do it
don't do it you better not you are not a
cop
don't you puked on my dress and
then you're a mad man no no no no no you
shut up Donnie just shut
up whoa dude Ice Ice
Baby what is Vanilla Ice doing in our
room my other best friend to your and W
A good rapper give it up for him come on
now word to your
grandma want a mannequin respect it my
mannequin my mannequin but you were only
13 she took a vantage all right I don't
know we were kind of like soulmates you
know we always there was a connection
there I never had it with anyone else
wow oh wow do not touch these place I'm
cleaning them okay Su a he treats them
like people oh hey big man what's going
on I had to go with the lady you patch
things up
pocket beer the dry cleaner said they've
uh definitely seen that combo of fluid
before you see yeah those things go
together like Jin and tonic well they
rhyme with Jin and tonic I wonder if
that's intentional CU that's actually
kind of clever I left you a little best
man gift on your dresser you did not
where are you anyways decided to go see
Mom after all yep you did what
uhoh the game is a foot
so we
duard now who's playing the older
version of the mother it's aliceon jany
what are you doing here we got to get
out of here now can we just blow this
place off and have a beer please I'm
begging you look is that her here we
go here we go it is
Suson I was about to joke are they going
to get Susan sandon that's awesome all
the more awesome when you open imdp and
discover who's that is she agreed to
this
too you were made foring me hi Mom I
didn't know if I'd ever see you again oh
I'm sorry I stopped visiting it just got
too hard oh no I totally understand a is
that the earring that I gave you after
the Lover Boy concert yes it is Miss
mcaro oh I love you so much m m girl I
never stopped oh I love you
too do you remember
oh God here we go all the nasty things
oh my God that I taught you Donnie oh
yes a real
American yeah I'm the dirtiest boy
you'll ever know Miss
M oh my
God oh my Jesus Oh My in front of the
boy uhhuh EXC FR now I'm is that the
Boom the boom dipped into frame what
happened
there oh oh oh it's the show it's the
show all right all right that was that
was what are you doing here must be
quite emotional for you to be face to
face with the woman who your father what
is going on right now who is this dude
dude this is why you came to see me for
some reality TV Ambush how much they
paying you Donnie nothing I swear to God
I'm I'm not getting $50,000 to deliver
you to this prison why would you say
that why would you do that I would never
take his money Tommy burger what have
you done Tommy burger this is something
that can be fixed you're unreal what you
go after him Donnie and you take care of
our
son
Jesus if I don't give him 43 G's by
Tuesday I'm going to prison if I give
you 43 Grand you don't have to go to
jail would you owe me the money no you
this is how ow That's my boy don't tase
me boy that's boy got one got one got
one more one more [__] his pants tell me
you got
no
no I hate
you Dad
oh good call don't hold on to it don't
let it you got to let it go let it flow
let it go
[Laughter]
free jeez man a of course his car
finally dies after 20 plus years you
really [__] the bet on this one Donnie
and Han really [__] the pants on this
one yeah keep it running I pick my [__]
up keep it running Nick Swardson Bucky
lson hey
oh no no I know but I told you not to
call me on this line what if Topic's up
yeah you knew it cheating no Steve Todd
doesn't know anything I don't care if he
finds out after the wedding there's
nothing he can do about it then anyway
what is your
game Steve
speir you up damn I thought she was
going to be cheating with the brother
same right I thought that's where they
were going with this seemed a little too
close I made my decision and who my new
partner is Phil Phil I knew you could do
it I'm just busting you Phil I never
pick
you
Partners give be a lot more hours and a
lot more responsibility a lot more time
away from your wife and a lot more money
ug ug Ranger holic is coming out it's
going to be here oh man need to charge
you this is not about you and me all
right you're not man marrying a right
girl she is cheating on you you are
unbelievable uh-oh this is my last
chance to be normal you determin to ruin
my life honey what's going on nothing
don't honey him you little snake in the
grass your wife to beast in your boss
uhoh I was on the phone with Steve Steve
Goldstein the Boston Herald wedding
reporter smell that uh I think I smell
it smells like [__] smell some
[__] conclusion might be that I'm an
[__] have a good good witty good
whiffs can't wait to get back to the
beach house oh no honey I'm staying in
the city tonight what no yeah the bride
and groom they're supposed to sleep
separate night before the wedding but
the the dress thing doesn't matter dad
you guys got the Hedgehog okay love you
you're SC your brother yeah I think so
wait but don't they not have a
car all right Donny go there's your
chance you got more chances buddy the
kid hates my guts Jamie's a gatekeeper
for your son where her over then she'll
convince H give you another chance boom
it's not a bad idea I'm to Peterson no
you're not it's your Donnie Berger you
teacher in the seventh
grade hi I'm Char Peterson he Mr
Peterson what can I do for
you interesting
joke what room was my fiance in again
641 hey when the legendary Donnie Burger
comes in here using a fake name you go
with it all right I will you go with it
oh what did Tod come out here you half
the size of Todd but you use it so much
better I guess not
wow oh no oh no it's her brother the ice
cream what is going to happen with this
ice
cream oh my god oh
terrifying sock
beer nice not bad man you got
too who do not deserve these sweets are
you finished
sweetheart oh my God the brother this
really gets me upset cuz he's too good
for you and you're sitting here
gallivanting with Mr Steve
Goldstein
yeah yep yep seemed pretty clear from
the beginning
with am I this is
oh my God Don don't understand what's
going on here I don't think Charlie
Sheen would understand what's going on
here yes I I I've had Chad from time to
time it's what Gooding people do they
have with other goodlooking
[Music]
people just so happens that this one
particular good-looking person is my
little brother this is such a weird
movie
I I know that s of Happ joh this was
going to be the last time I would never
carry on with a married woman I've got
pet morals than that Donnie woof
adultery is bad but
it yes please don't let him tell Mommy
about her secret tickle
time no not secret tickle time no no no
no tickle time is crazy I'm chilling
char No he won't believe you you think
he got that partnership on his own no I
give him a boost how many people have
you well maybe he'll believe
this those games give in all right how
much I'm going to be a very rich woman I
can write you a big fat check what do
you think he's going to do when he finds
out about this Todd's happy you really
want to take that away no he's going to
transform when he finds out become a
whole new man take the money and then
tell her anyway
there you go I got the money your son
came through for you didn't he his
fiance gave me $50,000 to keep quiet
about her having with her brother I've
been there we've all been
there we've all been
there yeah
man oh the present he got him oh the m
the m go do
something I don't know Mr to me I don't
know if I can handle it
[Music]
no no no don't hit
me and I hope that you'll accept my
apology and allow me the honor of being
part of this joyous day what about
father Shak oh stupid bird come on
fly let's go was it you that hit me in
the head with the bottle it was
Chad yes my man get it get it those jazz
hands you still get the
5.0 is that a yes or no I don't
understand the pose yeah let's go let's
go B boy is always yes go I go ice save
my son
mix yeah rev that 90s
Mustang damn get it they totally
crunched they they crunched the hood so
many times in movies you'll see them
take a jump the car will land you'll see
the hoods start to buckle and then you
cut to like a fresh car like so many of
those jumps would total these vehicles
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah Whoa man you stuck yep Oh I thought
they were going to like jump into the
ocean
[Music]
nah oh God Jesus
no no no no no no pause attraction run
for it man but we need great Dunes I got
a Walkman you got the boom box or the
Walkman just is good let's
go the
headphones test part I
do I love that there are just like
random model beautiful women
around a the the beat you jumped there's
a door right
here hey man he climbed the green
monster all right even if it wasn't the
real one he's a real one don't answer
that
question yep yep
yep we ran well over a
[Laughter]
mile in how many minutes
right it's this realistic
yeah I am je to these two get married oh
we're we're past that part already what
are my options then how about leaving
you shut the hell up you satanic hose
bag whoa you'll understand why he said
that in a few minutes ain't going to be
a few minutes you
goddamn uhoh oh who got him Mr boy talk
of course Grahams got it you don't love
this girl your cell phone with you you
got the evidence yeah I had love it's
different it's a different feeling love
is like just leads you to a special
connection it's it's full of like
feelings feelings you you you you that
wrap around you it's deep in your
stomach it's in your head it's in
your okay I've had just about enough of
this Phil sit down before I tell your
wife what you did to the strip club
okay Phil son I'm sorry I just I can't
let you marry this skank what what is he
talking about you can tell me I'll
forgive you that's what Love's about
right forgiveness
leverage he's my father I lied because
I'm the product of an inappropriate
teacher student relationship do you know
how gross that sounds you're disgusting
are you [__] kidding me right now yes
yeah she can still cancel that check
Donnie I was going to hold on to it you
know to get me out of jail but yeah
that's what I think it is that's how
much I hate
this jeez don't listen to him he's a
liar and he's crazy what is going on
tell him yeah no no no no no no no no
don't talk don't
talk that's convincing yep please no God
no he's good in the gr Bradley Cooper
rooll of this Wedding
Crashers uh yeah just kiss your brother
already you may kiss the bro okay well
that's not that bad what you didn't tell
him you lion piece of [__] get on it now
or off Crush you whoa oh boy oh boy you
can tell me how bad could it be oh boy
bad
what okay she
told yeah that's the response your
[Music]
brother there it is white
people that's what I'm talking
about it's going to be even better now
you're a mess I'm a mess come on Dr
shako get your ass up here I don't know
if you're all the same kind of
mess oh ice man shaking his head go get
with that black chick from the strip
club bro you deserve better let's not do
this and for the record my name's not
Ted Peterson it's Han Solo named after
the man who made the Kastle Run in less
than 12 par sex that's right you know
that's right that's right Steve uh
nothing personal man but I quit we quit
the to you yes good call on solo cuz
your fiance to it's all right Steve cuz
guess what Donnie and Vanilla Ice your
mom Vanilla Ice grandma
Yeah that close up oh
boy
Whoa beer botle always the beer word to
your mother brother who
bars bars to vanilla eyes naps to
vanilla eyes baby I'm going to kill
you yes that's my
boy
yes the Jaz the
Jaz
no let's get out of here Dad did you he
my son called me dad that right the
Burger Boys Are Back [__] the Burger
Boys Are Back The Burger Boys Are
[Laughter]
Back dad let me just give you the money
I'm not going to do that it's time for
Donny Burger to take responsibility for
his screw-ups turn on a TV turn it on uh
oh fat guy we've been talking about
allain yes
is this the fat guy who put the money on
20 bucks at 8,000
one 16 Grand
beep no
no yes come on toque you got
this this chocolate milk chocolate milk
god damn these wieners will give me the
quick energy I need to
[Applause]
escape
wow yes yes my friend get it get it
toots get
it freeze
frame what a weird little
button oh
wow what a fun what a fun movie that was
quite
something oh my god wow it's funniest
movie I've seen in a minute I need a
moment to put myself back together
so I think now is an appropriate time uh
for for Greg to step in with a little
message from the people who made this
video
possible roll Those ads
[Laughter]
baby Aloha reject Nation Greg here so as
many of you guys know most of my days
are a couple of hours of filming and
then most of the time it's dedicated to
like editing and a bunch of other
computer work often accumulating to like
10 to 12 hours a day and on top of that
comfort food is like my life's biggest
Vice but as many of you also know
working out and getting healthier has
been a massive component for me this
year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for
quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have
subscribed to prior to ever agreeing and
working with them so yes this is a
genuine testimony and that is of course
for hello fresh and helloof fresh is in
just about ease about bringing health
and flavor to your doorstep in this
holiday season forget about the stress
of planning meals for your health
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hellofresh I'm looking
forward to hosting holiday dinners that
are not only delicious but also cater to
Healthy Lifestyles best part the variety
it is incredible I'm pescatarian so they
have these delicious meals just like
dejon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and for my more
plant-based days the vegan Maple carrot
power bowls they aren't just meals
they're culinary Adventures I learned
the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while
cooking and that's where helloof Fresh's
15minute meals are a lifesaver they're
quick nutritious and Oho tasty perfect
for my non-stop lifestyle so why not
join me in making this holiday season
both health conscious and delicious with
hellofresh with over 45 recipes and
seasonal add-ons to choose from every
week there's always something new to try
and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com rejects free and use
code rejects free for free breakfast for
life is that accurate that sounds way
too good to be true there's no way that
can be sure go to hellofresh.com reex
free and use code reject free for free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box as long as your subscription is
active tag your hellofresh creations
with # hellofresh pick and @ hellofresh
and let's cook up some fun and
healthiness reject Nation remember it's
America's number one meal kit oh wow
well Aaron who we we we we that my void
we void boy we boy how do you what did
you think how do you feel right now oh
man I feel so many things uh yeah dude
that movie was crazy that was a wild
experience yes it was yeah I really
liked it I was like you know Adam
Sandler these days has been kind of hit
or miss with the comedies oh it's Eva
Murray not uh Katherine Isabelle my be
who Okay whoopsy Daisy all right yeah
but I you know I really liked it I
thought it was a lot of fun I mean I
thought it was really runchy I thought
it was super duper funny thought I had a
heart in the midst of all this this
vulgarity and riness and this movie was
never afraid to push the envelope and
just like take every joke to like the
nth degree and I respected the movie a
lot for that yeah I think more than
anything just like it made me laugh a
lot and I haven't seen a comedy that's
made me laugh like this hard in a minute
so I'm shocked this movie came out like
2012 from what I saw before we started
the movie so like it's like 11 years old
it still holds up a the Sandler kids are
in it the Sandler kids he did a movie
with them recently the uh the sweet 16
movie okay they're pretty good it I
thought they're pretty good runs in the
fam runs in the fam sand fam no watching
The Fan the sand fam bam I agree this is
you know
uh Ranch
she you know like this isn't the exact
kind of Comedy I'm always seeking out
but it is one I can certainly have fun
with and and yeah I mean this is
certainly pushing all the buttons of of
you know gross out and vulgarity and and
crassness and whatever else but yeah I I
agree I think you know there's something
Charming about that I'm learning that
the Adam Sandler Vibe you know is like
movies with a bit of heart for people
who really love to like rib each other
and and like you know bro out in a in a
very kind of masculine sort of way I
guess is is this I don't think those are
the perfect words for it but that's kind
of what I got right now so yeah it's
like this is one of those movies with
where the setup and the and the prologue
is so wild and you're like
I I I don't know how to feel about it
because part of me is like this is
making light of such a strange kind of
situation but at the same time like this
is the exact kind of thing that would
make uh in some respects a perfect like
ronchi Hollywood comedy so like oh yeah
like I don't think they can make this
kind of movie today like even though
this is like barely over a decade old I
did highly doubt that this would get
green lit think yeah it's on that cusp
where you're like I do understand how
this got made and like the weird Loop it
goes through in that you have bookends
of these like wild and and inappropriate
you know entanglements
uh you know so it just makes me curious
about you know who conceived this and
and how they crashed all these elements
together but you know that said like I
did think that it made a lot of you know
it delivered on once you get past what
however you feel about like the real
world implications of a premise like
this like it delivers on what the
premise promises you and I mean Adam
Sandler is somebody who for me you know
kind of varies in the sense that I
usually like him more in character roles
than the roles where he's sort of just
playing himself um and this more borders
on a character role for me Ian he's
doing the ad I'm s the voice but he's
got you know he's got the Boston accent
he he's he's dedicated enough to being
this dead beat so like I enjoyed
watching him I'm an Andy Samberg fan in
general and I thought he made a good
straight man uh for this and uh yeah I
liked all the kind of wacky random Side
characters like this is like feel like
Wedding Crashers came out and kind of
had this interesting moment where it was
like you know this
is it's still got like you know crude
humor elements obviously but it is like
aimed a little more adult whereas this
is like I feel like very much aimed at
like the kids who are him and the
prologue you know where was like that's
the kind of Target for this kind of
humor but at the same time it's giving
you just so much of it so constantly I I
sort of call that BL Force comedy where
it's just like it's it's doing so much
of its brand of humor that you kind of
have to just give up and and you know it
just sort of forces you yeah to
surrender into laughter so like so yeah
I had a lot of fun and I laughed a lot
and I can't pretend like I didn't yeah
know like granted it was one of those
movies that's like having a Thousand
Mile a minute with its jokes and has
like a little bit of dips of heart here
and there but yeah I think the rate at
which it's pumping out these these jokes
so frequently like it's hitting more
than it's in for me which makes it an
overall enjoyable experience sure yeah
absolutely and like the just the
absurdity of the situ and like little
running gags and stuff like I love that
he's got beer bottles just like
everywhere um you know and and that the
whacking people with the bottle you
recurring bit and the underwear yeah
it's there are a lot of things Beyond
like this didn't feel like a one of the
Laz or Adam Sandler comedies in that
like it's the way people ribon like
grown-ups for being like Oh you just got
your friends together and went someplace
nice and you decided to maybe justify
that by making a movie whereas you know
I mean the setup again is like I
absolutely see how this was a script
idea somebody was like oh yeah I could
sell this right right you know uh and uh
and yeah like I was very Charmed by the
omelet the bacon and legs strip club and
like his especially like um I forget
what her name is the the lady who works
there and stuff like that I think it's
Sierra dude I want to like confirm that
yeah we need to get the IMDb for That's
My Boy her but also the other woman who
uh was she in like Borat or something uh
either way yeah like you you can tell
where some of this is going but yeah in
a way that that felt you know at least
rounded enough for what it is and uh
yeah it's weird it's like it's one of
those movies that forces you to
entertain so many like Odd Ideas but
like it was
Sierra well done my friend lunell hey
that's her name yeah and she is in like
Borat and stuff uh yeah some good
character actors in here and whatnot
always love seeing a little Will
Forte um but yeah and then James like
I'm always fascinated too that that Adam
Sandler is able to get people to show up
who have like you know pretty high
caliber filmogs and and you know uh oh
this guy who played Chad was pretty
familiar too um but yeah he's he's he's
able to get veterans to like show up for
these kinds of things wait wait oh
that's the dude from This Is Us guy from
This Is Us oh my God I'm I'm not caught
up on the US I've only seen like the
first few episodes I need to get back on
I'm used to seeing him being very
emotional yeah czy see him in this mode
which is like a very it's like Bradley
Cooper in Wedding Crashers he's that
kind of character where he's like you
know a little raged out a little roed up
you know he's actually never seen
wedding crashes before oh well put that
on the list that's a great one damn put
that on the list for sure um and no Rob
Schneider
Cameo you said earlier he's on the Adam
Sandler bingo card does Vanilla Ice
appear in a lot of Adam Sandler movies I
feel like he does I feel like he appears
in both Adam Sandler and Rob Schneider
joints he's he's at least done a couple
and haven't seen ridiculous six
ridiculous oh I mean he started in his
own movie cool as ice he was in Sandy
Wexler Adam Sandler movie that's my boy
uh he was in the uh inan clown posi
movie uh he's in the new guy which is
not a a Sandler movie but you know it's
a it's a bit of a you know runch comedy
for sure of course he us Ninja Turtles
too secret of the oo so I mean not
everyone but he is buds with uh Adam
Sandler it does seem like because yeah
he's at least done a few of these now um
so you know I'm always amused by the
appearance of Rob Van Winkle I called
him Travis vanwinkle at one point during
the reaction Travis vanwinkle is the guy
who always plays Trent in movies movies
um but yeah uh you know for an Adam
Sandler Annie Samberg team up you know I
enjoyed the way they played off each
other you know where the Beats of their
relationship are going to go um but uh
you know yeah it's it's it's still
manages to leave you more feeling or
lift me feeling more of the fun in the
heart than you know the the more
questionable elements of the film's
Inception I agree and yeah like James KH
freaking showed up and so did Susan
sandon and that one brief scene just
like she killed it these vets man yeah I
was like damn Susan random makeing me
feel things yeah and you could tell
she's like oh wow like she's really
bringing this performance to someone who
hasn't seen their son in so many years
it's like having a family reunion yeah
and something I'll say is like the the
younger version of her and the older
version both felt like the same person
which I really appreciated they brought
that same like just like exaggerated
like sexual energy to the role I liked I
was like okay I see you I see you better
yeah totally and I mean you know as far
as the premise itself does go I mean you
at least I don't know like it's kind of
having its cake and eating it too but I
guess it it kind of tempers Itself by
showing that this guy is you know a dead
beat and that you know being this
juvenile I don't know I mean yeah being
this juvenile mindset will probably get
you into a hole like this where you're
desperate and you know you're washed up
and all that but you know also at the
same time you know being that juvenile
minded person Saves the Day in a lot of
ways so you know yeah it's a total like
wacky farce comedy but uh you know yeah
for what it is I had fun I also pretend
like it didn't it's very yeah I give it
like a 7.5 out of 10 sure I'll meet you
around there seven seven and a half
something like that a good time yeah
it's not like the most clever comedy but
there were a couple clever jokes here
and there that I did appreciate and
again like the combin of the
performances and the wackiness you know
it certainly bowled me over and I was
always kind of you know surprised by
what was happening and things that were
going on so I mean I I got to give it
that
too you know like uh it definitely had
me like squirming and and chuckling
either in spite of things or genuinely
at stuff so yeah you know probably you
know slap a big old problematic I guess
if you want to on just like the whole
conception of this movie but uh but yeah
for what it is I don't think it's O
overly offensive yeah it's it's a movie
of its time you know like obviously it
wouldn't be made today it's so gleefully
offensive that it becomes inoffensive at
a certain point yeah yeah it's so over
the top like you know take anything that
happened seriously yeah man i' I'd
recommend it I'd show it to my friends I
had a fun time though you know yeah I I
would I would asterisk it I would be
like Hey listen like some of this is a
little some of the themes here are are a
little bit much but at the same time
yeah like as far as Adam Sandler
comedies go you know that I've seen
anyway uh yeah I mean I had fun and I
couldn't tell anybody that I didn't so
no yeah same here but anyway did you
guys have fun let us know down below let
us know what other uh movies you want to
see any other Adam Sandler joints you'd
like us to check out I haven't seen a
bunch of them neither well hey maybe we
that maybe we'll make that our thing uh
but yeah much love to you guys hope
you're all well you know kiss somebody
you love as long as they're not related
to you and uh you we'll see you on the
next one not on the lips no no
cheers ad voice